ja meine absolute negativ figur des
heutigen tages ist nicht armin laschet
aber eine frau aus seinem wahlkampfteam
nämlich karin prien da sehen wir sie
schon die bildungsministerin in
schleswig holstein ist die hat sich
heute nämlich nagen sie nicht erregt
über den handy alarm bei bild live der
handy alarm sie wissen es vielleicht
wenn sie bild live regelmäßig gucken ist
das handy von paul ronzheimer des
ständig schiebt und vibriert wenn eine
neue nachricht kommt wenn informationen
kommen heute also aus dem aus der
fraktionssitzung der union wo wir die
ganzen nachmittag über laien und als
erstes nachrichten hatten durch diesen
handy alarm und das hat eine politikerin
kein wegen der aus der fassung gebracht
man kann fast sagen sie ist
durchgeknallt weil sie hat folgendes
formuliert sie können es hier schon eine
weile lesen handy alarm ist die traurige
chiffre für die totengräber jedweder
vertrauensvollen zusammenarbeit und
jetzt kommt ein anschlag auf bundesrat
demokratie pad anschlag auf unsere
demokratie also da sind wir kurz
nachdenken es ist doch journalismus ist
es informationsbeschaffung es ist
pressefreiheit wer das als in wer das
als anschlag auf die demokratie sieht
oder wertet der will pressefreiheit
relativieren vielleicht sogar
abschaffung das will ich nicht
unterstellen auf jeden fall hat der oder
diejenige große probleme mit der
pressefreiheit und jetzt schauen wir
doch mal genauer ein was da eigentlich
geschehen ist die informationen kommen
ja irgendwoher und vielleicht liegen die
nerven bei kopien aus dem wahlkampfteam
von armin laschet auf dem untergehenden
dampfer von allen lastet einfach so
blank dass sie eine wichtige erkenntnis
aus der politischen system politischer
studium übersieht
indiskretionen gibt es immer nur in
niedergehenden systemen einfach mal
drüber nachdenken
also ich kann mich noch gut erinnern an
eine situation habe ich eine längere
rede in der fraktion gehalten und ich
weiß ja da sind ja kollegen die simsen
und ich während ich noch gesprächen habe
gab es die ersten dicker meldungen und
das für mich skandalöse war dass man
alles richten
das muss doch jeder wissen dass die zeit
der geschlossenen türen bleibt alles
unter uns vorbei ist ich habe meinen
leuten immer gesagt wenn man der
pressemeldung machen dann schreiben wir
nicht pressemeldung drauf sondern streng
vertraulich
muss doch jeder vista kann man doch
nicht so naiv sein zu glauben
dass man jetzt wenn man etwas raus gibt
dass das nicht veröffentlich wird also
ich traue selbstbild zu dass man fragt
ist das eine seriöse quelle kann man das
noch gegen recherchieren dass hier keine
wilden vermutungen verbreitet werden
sondern fakten auch wenn es mal dem
einen oder anderen nicht passt das mag
sein also ich glaube auch dass die
vorstellung die damit schwingt bei frau
bringen das dass es noch diese grund
gibt aus denen nichts nach draußen
dringen also vielleicht einen vier-
augen- spaziergang am strand das ist
vielleicht noch oder frühstücken oder
erfrischend in wolfratshausen dann weiß
man es vielleicht auch nicht oder und
wird heute 80
das ist eine vorstellung von gestern die
frage die mich aber seit ich die wut von
frau bringen ist ich mag das ja auch ich
mag auch wenn nicht alle immer so
abgeklärt auf alles der hat es gestunken
und nazi alt früher hätte man irgendwie
den nebenmann beschimpft oder angerufen
oder den chef der angerufen oder sonst
irgendwas heute twittert man halt
eigentlich finde ich das ganz gut weil
es nicht so emotionslos und nur ständig
ausgleichen aber sie setzt das schimmert
dadurch etwas voraus was ist ja nie
geben darf nämlich so eine hinter den
türen geheimdiplomatie fund denen die
die es eigentlich betrifft und ange bloß
nichts erfahren sollen nämlich die
bürger und ich habe vorhin mal rein
gelesen also die bürger schimpfen ganz
schön schon über sie im sinne von na ja
also das ist uns zehnmal lieber wenn
journalisten wenn bild so was macht als
das ihr dahin dürfen sich die senioren
des hauses in der unions fraktion jetzt
genau das was man sich eigentlich seit
sonntagabend 18 uhr gewünscht hätte in
der union und die wählerinnen und wähler
haben ja auch ein anrecht nicht dieses
schauspiel die ganze zeit zu erleben wir
haben einen regierungsauftrag und wir
wollen jamaika und es ist alles
wunderbar und wir haben ja eigentlich
doch wirklich gewonnen sondern die haben
natürlich ein anrecht auch zu erfahren
dass es hinter den kulissen durchaus
härter zugeht und dass da auch mal
tacheles geredet wird einigen die braut
prien denjenigen die da auch das ein
oder andere aus der fraktionssitzung
austragen und zum handy alarm bei wild
beitrag eigentlich dankbar sein denn es
wird zeigt ja dass in ihrer partei
erfährt der bosbach auch viele sind die
das ähnlich sie ihn an weil sein visier
ganz normalen bürger eigentlich die
sagen dass etwas schief gelaufen zieht
die konsequenzen und und genau das ist
seine frau prinz dankbar sein bei uns
direkt dankbar sein
ich finde es erstaunlich wie blank die
nerven offenbar jetzt schon liegen also
wirklich die die wale sei jetzt noch
nicht besonders lange her und man kann
sich wahrscheinlich darauf das eine oder
andere lied aus den
koalitionsverhandlungen dann freuen
sagen wir mal die die wohlwollen der esa
tiere streets ist ja noch die dass er
sich nicht an die journalisten richtet
weil das wäre nun wirklich unsinnig denn
irgendwie das recht abzusprechen solche
dinge zu veröffentlichen sondern dass er
sich nur ein versprechen an diejenigen
politiker parteikollege richtet die
dinge durchrechnen und das ist natürlich
schon auf einer ebene nachvollziehbar
dass ein das frustriert die würde ich
das oder ist das alles noch ist es für
zwei kredite das ist das viel daran
finde ich aber ist es also es war
vielleicht der auch die frage an sie aus
ihrer erfahrung also würden sie sagen in
welchen situationen ist man als
politiker tatsächlich in der pflicht mal
die füße still zu halten oder wann ist
das legitim dinge heraus zu geben gibt
es da jetzt gerade mit blick auf die
koalitionsverhandlungen für sie sind für
mich gibt es immer ein kriterium schadet
oder nützt es
der eigene trotz entschuldigung
natürlich habe ich habe auch an dem
abend der entscheidung weil der
konkurrenz war da aber fair gesagt mein
favorit ist markus söder aber es wird
armin laschet ist es geworden jetzt
merkel ich nicht rum sondern machen
monate lang bundesweit für ihn wahlkampf
so stelle ich mir parteiarbeit vor dann
haben wir ein ergebnis eingefahren was
traurig hoch drei ist da kann ich nicht
zufrieden sein dann stört mich auch
lauter applaus muss ich auch in meinem
eigenen wahlkreis ist jetzt bei der
zweiten wahl glatt halbiert worden von
58 prozent auf 29 mit kann ich nicht
leben damit kann ich nicht zufrieden
sein das heißt wir müssen aufpassen dass
wir nicht ein paar ein universum bilden
und nicht mehr wissen was draußen gesagt
und gedacht wird was heißt
regierungsauftrag wir haben die chance
eine koalition zu bilden nicht mehr und
nicht weniger aber da raus aus diesem
ergebnis auftrag oder anspruch
abzuleiten das ist vermessen ich finde
diesen punkt schadet oder nützt es
meiner truppe als frage sehr sehr
interessant weil man ja glaube ich schon
sagen kann wenn aus einer aus einem
gremium oder einer großen versammlung
viele dinge nach außen kommen viele
dinge nach außen getragen werden dann
entscheiden offensichtlich vieles nutzt
mir aber nicht der trainer ist ja gut
und dann ist es mit der truppe dann ist
irgendwo probleme der truppe das habe
ich mir irgendwie ganze zeit gedacht wie
schrecklich ist das eigentlich jetzt
achtung naiv an fall aber wie
schrecklich ist es eigentlich wenn du
als cdu kanzlerkandidat nach einer
aufregenden wahl und jetzt kritisieren
laschet ja aber man kann auch nicht oft
genug betont ist ein anständiger mann
also wirklich ein anständiger mann der
sich da eingebracht hat der auch für
ziele kämpft der eben nicht so der
grelle darsteller ist aber ein ansteigen
der ring ein ende nimmt das gegenteil
also dann würde man auch glauben dass
man irgendwie gut aufgehoben ist wenn
man sich dem anvertraut der gehört schon
zu denen wo ich das gefühl aber nicht
eine sorge hätte ich kenne ihn jetzt
nicht persönlich aber wenn es so gerne
dem kann man sich anvertrauen also der
register nicht würde auch mal haben wir
ein legoland sondern minister muss
dass muss achtung laut dazu zu ende aber
noch ein bisschen mitleid
was sagt das eigentlich wenn der cdu
kanzler kandidat nach einer geschlagenen
schlacht nach einer klaren niederlage
mit blut schweiß und tränen in
wahlkämpfer dem in seiner homebase nach
haus in die fraktion kommt und dort
geschlachtet wird das ist doch irgendwie
ein also das kann man sich ja gar nicht
das ist ein drama nach dem 3
[Musik]